coming up next week at the Strasburg
plenary a taxing time for any Peas as
they delve into the Panama papers
scandal and farmers do battle with
supermarkets welcome to the agenda
remember what it felt like when you got
your school abroad card did you have any
expectations well for Commission
President jean-claude Juncker is not
quite fun grading season but his
investment plan is a premature review
over three years 315 billion euros worth
investment was to be mobilized by a 21
billion euro initial guarantee secured
through the EU budget and European
Investment Bank to boost growth in
Europe the Commission has released
figures showing that a hundred billion
years has been generated but what will
Emily's make of the public and private
initiatives undertaken the midterm
review is the first item of the day on
Wednesday tax evasion is an offence a
bit tax avoidance however immoral isn't
illegal but following on from big
scandals such as the lux leaks and there
the more recent Panama papers nubes
politicians want stricter measures you
try to close tax loopholes in Strasbourg
any fees will vote on the 12-month
mandate and number of em eps to be
assigned to the inquiry committee set up
in the wake of the Panama papers scandal
and the vote on the Commission's tax
avoidance director took place on Tuesday
and if he's are calling for fifteen
percent corporate tax rate for foreign
investments many commonly use electronic
devices toys and even make up like this
can contain chemicals that are harmful
to the human body they can affect our
hormones and in worst case scenario
called cancer the endocrine system is
made up of glands that produce hormones
which regulate growth metabolism and
sexual development and function in
December 2015 the European Court of
Justice ruled the Commission had
breached EU law by failing to act on
endocrine disrupters exposure to these
chemicals effects fetal development
puberty they can also cause reproductive
disease and
answer mbps will reiterate their call to
get the Commission to publish scientific
studies on endocrine disruptors at the
plenary on Wednesday and now for the
news in brief on Thursday any peace
could green lights a regulation to
simplify procedures are proving the
authenticity of public documents such as
birth and marriage certificates in other
member states no more David versus
Goliath MVP's want to level the playing
field to help farmers better compete
against supermarkets a proposal will be
tabled in plenary and voted on Tuesday
the EU foreign affairs chief at Freddie
oh c'mon oriini will be at plenary to
discuss funds to help migrant countries
of origin particularly Africa the debate
along with a discussion on the legal
migration package is on Tuesday
sub-saharan Africa has the highest
prevalence of hunger and EU g8 backed
initiative to boost agriculture and
relieve poverty could be set for a
makeover the new alliance for food
security and nutrition in Africa was
launched a 2012 with a aim to ramp up
foreign investment in farming to the
tune of eight billion dollars it's
believed that sub-saharan African
farmers produce eighty percent of the
world's food Emmie peas are calling for
better safeguards prevent land grabbing
and corruption and that's all we have
this agenda take care and enjoy the week